من العربيه يقدمها لكم هذا المساء صهيب
شراير ونتابع فيها
زلزال سوريا وتركيا لماذا كان مدمرا وهل
ما زال الخطر قائما
هل كان بالامكان تفادي اثار الزلزال
المدمر بتركيا ام ان قوه الزلزال فاقت كل
التوقعات
بعد موافقه النظام معابر جديده لدخول
المساعدات عبر تركيا هل هي كافيه ام ان
حجم الماساه يتطلب تنحيه السياسه وفتح
جميع المعابر
مرت تسعه ايام على الزلزال العنيف الذي
بلغت قوته 7.8 درجات وضرب تركيا وسوريا
والذي وصلت ارتداداته الى دول المنطقه حيث
شعر بها السكان في لبنان العراق مصر وقبرص
الزلزال المدمر الذي وقع فجر الاثنين
السادس من فبراير ضرب مناطق شمال سوريا
وحول محافظات حلب واللاذقيه وحماه وادلب
الى مناطق منكوبه اما في تركيا فاثار
الزلزال المدمر تركزت في محافظتي كرمان
مراش وغزي عنتاب وصولا الى محافظه هاتاي
ومركزها انطاكيا الزلزال الكبير احدث
دماارا كبيرا في كلا البلدين واسقط عشرات
الاف الضحايا من قتلى وجرحى وشرد الملايين
الحصيله تجاوزت 37 الف قتيل في البلدين
عدا عن انهيار وسقوط الاف المباني التي
تحولت الى تلال من الركام كما تسبب في صدع
يمتد لما يزيد على 100 كيلومتر بين
الصفيحه الاناضوليه والصفيحه العربيه
الزلزال انتهى لكن هزاته الارتداديه
القويه لم تتوقف حيث اعلنت اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه تسجيل اكثر من 2000 هزت
ارتداديه منذ وقوع الزلزال المدمر يطلق
على الهزات الارتداديه توابع الزلزال وهي
تحدث وفق تفسير خبراء الجيولوجيا نتيجه
محاوله الصفائح التكتونيه العوده الى
مكانها على طول خط الصدع بعد حدوث الزلزال
الاشد وقد تستمر لايام واحيانا لاشهر
زلزال تركيا وسوريا مساحات واسعه تحولت
الى مناطق منكوبه الزلزال ضرب معظم
الولايات الجنوبيه من تركيا اضنه اليامان
ديار بكر غازي عنتاب هاتايا قهرمان مرعش
كلس ملاطيا عثمانيه شانلي اورفا وفي سوريا
المناطق المتضرره كانت في محافظات حلب
واللاذقيه وحماه وادلب تقديرات صادمه
لخسائر الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا في تركيا
خسائر الزلزال تصل لاربعه وثمانين مليار
دولار توقع ارتفاع عجز الموازنه من ثلاثه
ونصف المئه الى 5.4 على الاقل في سوريا
يصعب تحديد حجم الاضرار الاقتصاديه التي
اصابت البلاد مقارنه بالجانب التركي بسبب
الاوضاع السياسيه المنقسمه ومعاناه البلاد
من حرب مستمره منذ اكثر من 12 عاما منظمه
الخوذ البيضاء اكثر من 375 مبنى انهار
كليا واكثر من الف ومئتين مبنى انهار
جزئيا
اذا نناقش الموضوع من عمان مع غسان سويدان
رئيس مركز رصد الزلازل الاردني ومن باريس
الدكتور بدوي الرهبان الخبير في الزلازل
والكوارث الطبيعيه وتغير المناخ مرحبا
بكما ضيفي الكريمين ضيفي من عمان ابدا معك
مشاهد دمار وصفها بعض وكانها تشبه نهايه
العالم وكما تابعنا في جميع الفيديوهات
على شاشات التلفزيون في الاخبار وحتى على
السوشيال ميديا البنايات تتهاوى يعني كما
اللعب
والالاف تشردوا الملايين تشردوا الالاف
قتلوا جراء هذا الزلزال لماذا كل هذا
الدمار في زلزال تركيا وسوريا
مساء الخير للجميع وشكرا للاستضافه
حقيقه انه ما حصل هو زلزال مدمر زلزال
كبير جدا يعد واحد من رابع اكبر الزلازل
التي سجلت على اليابسه خلال السنوات
الماضيه او القرن الماضي زلزال لم يكن
يتوقعه احد وكما تعلم انه هذه مناطق
ماهوله بالسكان ومناطق حيويه ومدن رئيسيه
وقرى فمن الطبيعي ان يكون هناك دمار كبير
لهذا الاثر الزلزالي على المنطقه
نعم طيب يعني انت تعتبر انه الزلزال بسبعه
فاصل سبعه او سبعه فاصل ثمانيه يعني هو
زلزال قوي يعني فمن الطبيعه ان نشهد كل
هذا الدمار
نعم طبيعي جدا سيدي انت لا تتكلم فقط عن
زلزال واحد تتكلم عن زلزال كبير زلزال
مهول وتبعه زلزال اخر بعد التسع سنوات وما
بين الزلزال الاول والزلزال الثاني هناك
عده هزات او زلازل ارتداديه وكانت واحده
منها يعني بعد عشر دقائق كان قوه السته
وسبعه بالعشره وهذا بحد ذاته زلزال مدمر
فانت يعني تتكلم عن مجموعه من الزلازل
خلال فتره وجيزه على مناطق ماهوله لمناطق
على حين غره كما يقال ان هذا الزلزال
اتينا على حين غره ليس هناك استعداد كافي
وحتى لو كان في استعداد كافي سيدي انت
بتتكلم عن زلزال قوي جدا زلزال بمقاييس
الخبراء فهو زلزال ضحل اي ان يعني بعدوا
عن مركز عن عن سطح الارض قليل يعني في ناس
بتتكلم على عشره كيلو في ناس تتكلم على
اكثر ولكن ما بين وهذا زلزال يعني بعلمنا
احنا
كمهندسين من الطبيعيه الكبيره جدا ورابع
اكبر يعني من رابع كبريات
الزلازل في العالم وخاصه انه على اليابسه
نعم دكتور بدوي
رهبان من واقع خبرتك في الكوارث والزلازل
زلزال تركيا
وسوريا حجم الدمار الذي شاهدناه هل يتوافق
مع قوه هذا الزلزال
طبعا ان قوه الزلزال هي عاليه نعرف ان
زلزال بدرجه صف 7.8 على مقياس ريشتل هو
زلزال قوي انما نعرف ان الزلازل تاتي بسبب
الفوالق الصدوع الجيولوجيه وكنا نعرف ان
الصدع الفالك الذي سبب هذا الزلزال نعرف
انه ممكن ان يحدث زلزالا بدرجه 7.8 اذا
هذه المعطية ليست جديده نعرف ان هذا النوع
من الفوالق يمكن ان يحدث الزلازل بدرجه
7.8 ولكن
فيما خص هذان الزلزالان هناك عوامل
تشابكت بعضها ببعض
لنذكر ان مثلا فيما خاصه تركيا هناك
معايير للبناء وهذه المعايير تم تجديدها
عام
1999 بعد زلزال الذي ضرب اسطنبول دكتور
بدوي اعذرني على المقاطعه انا مطر
لمقاطعتك مشاهدينا حصيله الزلزال ترتفع
الى 41 الف قتيل كلمه للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وطني ودولي ايضا بالاضافه الى
الحوامات والطائرات 76 طائره 126 حوامه
بالاضافه الى عشرات
البواخر والعديد من
الاليات الاخرى وبعد مرور ساعه طويله على
الزلزلين
ارتداديه الى الان ما زلت هنالك فرق البحث
والانقاذ يقومون
بانقاذ احياء وناجينا من مباني التي تحطمت
الاضافه الى القيام بانشاء مطابخ متنقله
ميدانيه ويقومون بتوزيع
ثلاث وجبات ساخنه
يوميا بالاضافه الى مياه
العديد من الخدمات الاخرى
قمنا بالتلقي
طلبات من مئه
الدوله بين فريقين للبحث والانقاذ الى
المساعدات
وثمانون دوله قدم اربعه دول انتهوا
عادوا الى دوالهم بالاضافه الى ان هنالك
مئات
مازالوا موجودون هذه اول مره تحدث هذه
الارقام الكبيره
بمشاركه الفرق الدوليه بهذه
الكلمه التي تعرضنا لها كان هنالك اتصالات
لنا مع عشرات القدم والزعماء ما بين رئيس
للدول
الوزراء كما قمنا باستقبال الامير القطري
وجميع المسؤولين
قاموا بتقديم التعاجي هذا بالاضافه الى
استقبالنا للمساعدات من اكثر من سبعا
وستين دوله من اسيا الى افريقيا الى
امريكا الى اوروبا جميع الدول
الصديقه
والشعوب
الشقيقه قاموا بارسال هذه المساعدات الى
جمهوريه التركيه جميع هذه الدول الشقيقه
وحليفه اشكر الدول
والشعوب باسمي وباسم شعبي الى تعازيم
الحاره بالاضافه الى مساعدتهم الماديه
والعينيه السيدات الصدر لميونه
الاعزاء ما زال جميع الفرق تعمل سنقوم
ببذع قصار جهدنا من اجل الوصول الى اخر حي
ومن ثم ازاله
قلب
والقيم بواجباتنا ومهامنا المقاتله عاتقنا
كما نقوم ايضا بمهامنا وواجباتنا
الانسانيه من اجل دفن جميع الضحايا
والتسليم الجزء الثالث الى ذويهم نبذ
القصار جودنا من اجل
بالمرحله الثانيه من اجل اعاده الاعمار
والبناء لمنازل والوحدات السكنيه بالاضافه
الى مكان العمل كما ستقوم وحده
سكنيه
العامه هي تابعه لحكومه
تقوم هذه المؤسسه ببناء جميع المباني
والشقق السكنيه التي تراعي شروط بناءها
وفق او المقاومه
الزلازل وبالتالي سنقوم بتسليم جميع
المواطنين الذين تضرروا مباني مقاومه
الزلازل خلال عاما واحد فقط
كما تعلمون كان هنالك العديد من المباني
كانت قد بنيت قبل قانون الذي تم اصداره
بعد زلزال عام 1999 نحن نعلم جيدا بانها
الرسائل
ورسائل لنا وبالتالي سنكون دقيقين
وحساسينا في بناء المباني الجديده وفق
شروط الصادره من الوسارات لمقاومه الزلازل
اذهب بالاضافه باننا قمنا باعطاء الاوامر
والتعليمات التي لا من اللازمه من اجل
اعاده البناء وتسليمها الى اصحابها
الحقيقيين سنقوم بالعمل بشكل مباشر
اعتبارا من شهر اذار مارس نقوم
بشكل مباشر بثلاثين
بناء هذا
بالاضافه نحن نعيد الجميع باننا خلال فتره
قصيره نقوم ببناء في جميع الولايات بما
ننهيه خلال عام واحدا لجميع المباني لتكون
هذه المباني امنه
ومقاومه للزلزال وتسليمها الى اصحابها
طبعا خلال هذا العام ما زالت هنالك نصب
لمخيمات بالاضافه الى تقديم الايجار لكل
اصحابي البيوت الذين يقومون الذين يريدون
الاقامه في بيوتين جائزه نحن عملنا خططنا
بشكل كامل من اجل تقديم الخدمات خلال عام
كما
نرجو ونتمنى من جميع مواطنين الصبر لمده
عام فقط كما نعد الجميع بتقديم دعم الكامل
لكل من يريد الاقامه في اي ولاده يريد بها
بتقديم
الدعم المادي لنقل امتعته كما كنا في
زلازل وان ملاطيا العجز بينجو وغيرها من
الولايات بالاضافه الى الولايات التي
تعرضت للشيول غراس وقسم بالاضافه الى
انطاليا وبولا التي تعرضت للحرائق كما كنا
خلال فتره قصيره جدا
بوصولي الى هذه المناطق السابقه التي
تتعرضت او التي تعرضت للكوارث الطبيعيه
وقمنا بتسليم جميع المباني والوحدات
السكنيه اليها خلال عامة
تجانبه بشكل
سنقوم ايضا بتسليمي الوحدات السكنيه
واماكن العمل خلال عام واحد لجميع
المتدرين في الولايات
عشره
جميعه المواطنين الذين تعرضوا لهذه
الكارثه ليعلم باننا الى جانبهم وسنعمل
ليلا ونهارا دون كلل من اجل التصدي
والوصول الى جميع مواطنين ومن اجل اعادتهم
الى الحياه الكريمه البارحه كنت في زياره
الى مستشفى تشام ساكورا وكنت في زياره
لجميع المنتظرين
من امهات واطفال وجميع العائلات
الذين كانوا يتطلقون علاج في تلك المستشفى
هنالك بعض المنكوبي ومتضررين
[موسيقى]
من اجل الاقامه الى جانب اقاربهم في ولايه
اسطنبول الى تلاقيهم
علاج بشكل مجاني في مستشفى تشام ساكورا
هذا بالاضافه الى استقبال العديد من
المستشفيات التابعه لوزاره
الصحابي الاشراف الكامل على جميع
المنكوبين والمتدرين والذين يطلقون العلاج
في جميع المستشفيات في مدينه اسطنبول هذا
بالاضافه باننا سنقوم بتقديم
خمسه عشره الفين في خمسه عشر الف ليره
تركيه الى جميع العائلات المنكوبه
بالاضافه الى
تقديمي 5000 لكل عائله تريد ان تنقل
امتعتها
الى جميع الولايات وتقديمي دعم
المحروقات
الى ذوي المركبات والاليات الذين يريدون
النقل الممتعتهم عبر الياتهم الخاصه
كما اننا سنقوم بتقديم الدعم عبر اجراء
تقييمات كامله في الاونه المقبله
في شبير
مظلومه صايب
نحن كحكومه وكشعب لن نترك اي مواطن
تضرر وتعرض لهذه كارثه الطبيعيه دون
الوصول اليه وتقديم الدعم الكامل
اعطينا اوامرنا وكلمتنا الكامله لجميع
الوزارات والمديريات العامه
التابعه لها
كما ستقوم جميع الوزارات
ومديريات ايضا
توجيهي نسبه كبيره من ارباحها الى الان
قرابه 50 مليار ليله ليره تركيه حتى الان
سنقوم بتخصيصها
والمتضرين في هذا في هذه الكارثه الطبيعيه
هذا بالاضافه سنقوم بتقديم الدعم الكامل
لجميع الحرفيين والصناعي واماكن العمل
كتقديمها كقروض لكل من يريد
افتتاح اماكن عمله مره اخرى
الوصول الى جميع المعامل والمصانع لاعاده
الحياه التجاريه
والصناعيه في جميع هذه الولايات كما يستعد
الجميع
باننا سنبذل قصارى جهودنا ايضا من اجل
تقديم الدعم
الكامل في مجال المصارف والبنوك وتاجيل
الديون
وقروت هذا بالاضافه
سيصل عدد المستفيدين من هذه القروض الى
اكثر من 650 الف مواطن هذا بالاضافه الى
مليارات
الليرات التركيه
الدعم يوم الاحد
تكون جميع قنوات التلفزه في اذربيجان وفي
شمال
قبرص التركيه سنكون هنالك
بمشاركه مع جميع الوزارات القيام
بحمله لحمله التبرع
للمتدرين يشارك فيها جميع الوزارات
ومنظمات المجتمع المدني
اكثر من
مليون ليره تركيه حتى الان بلغ حجم
التبرعات من
الوزارات
واصحاب الاعمال الخيره والمتطوعين والذين
يريدون المشاركه في هذه
في هذه حمليها حملات التبرع
السيدات الساده
الاعزاءنا
والنائبي بالاضافه الى جميع الوزاره
بالاضافه الى جميع الوزارات كنا مشاركين
في عمليات التنسيق الكامل من اجل الوصول
الى المواطنين
كما تعلمون زلزلان كبيران بالاضافه الى
شروط الشروط الجويه
الصعبه نبذ القصاره جهودنا من اجل اعاده
الحياه الى ما كانت عليها كما قمنا ايضا
بالتخصيص قرابه 800 مليون
بناء عاما بالاضافه الى وحدات السكن
الطلابيه
الى الان تم استقبال اكثر من مليون ونصف
مليون في هذه الوحدات والمباني العامه
بالاضافه الى نصب مخيمات
الجاهزه وتوزيع
البطانيات والمساعدات كما كان هنالك ايضا
عشر منازل جاهزه توجهت من قطر الى
الولايات المنكوبه
عشره الاف منزل جاهز
القطري الذي قام بعد بعد استخدامها
التي كانت مهياه
باحدث
الظروف
والشروط
العالميه من اجل استضافه كاس العام العالم
في عام 2022 في قطر الان تم وضعها في
الابواخر وستتوجه خلاده خلال ساعات الى
الولايات المنكوبه هذا بالاضافه
جميع حملات التبرع الالبسه والاغذيه وجميع
المستلزمات والاحتياجات اللازمه لجميع
المنكوبين ما زالت
مستمره عبر الجوي والبري
والبحر
الاساطير تقوم
بتقديمها وحملها
للوصول الى مناطق الزلزال كما انه هنالك
بعض الولايات
ممن فتحت فنادقها
مواطنين وضعنا جميع امكانيات وطاقتي
الجمهوريه التركيه
تحت خدمته الان منكوبين هذا بالاضافه قمنا
بفتح وحدات
الطلاب السكنيه الجامعيه ايضا دوله
انؤذي الطلاب الجامعيين امام جميع
المنكوبين
ومتضررين ليتم كان
هنالك الاف عاملين في الوزارات
والمديريات
بالاضافه الى المتطوعين ما زالوا يعملون
بنفس المعنويات
العشرين من شبهات ستكون جميع المدارس
والجامعات في الوالي الولايات غير
المتضرره بفتح
ابوابها
بالاضافه سيكون التعليم الجامعي عن بعد في
الولايات متضرره
سنقوم باضافه ولايه العزيز ولايه حاديه
عشره
ستكون هنالك هيئات تقوم
الدراسه والتمعين والفحص الكامل لجميع
المدارس
هل هي صالحه من اجل اعاده الطلاب اليها او
لا كما سنقوم ايضا بنقل الطلاب والمدارس
الى الولايات
المجاوره من اجل اكمال مدارسهم تقوم جميع
جميع الوزارات والقوات المسلحه التركيه
والقوات الامن الداخلي وقوات غفرت سواحل
وجميع
موظفين في
بلديات تبنوا هذه المهمه والواجب الاسلامي
ثلاثه وسبعين الف من القوات المسلحه اكثر
من 60 الف من الجندرمه يقومون بتقديم
الخدمات لمده
24 ساعه على مد
ملحمه وطنيه بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه بمشاركه
جميع الوزارات
ومتبرعين
المتطوعين القوات المسلحه البريه والبحريه
يبذلون قصارى جوديهم ايضا من اجل المشاركه
في ازاله الانقاض وتقديم المساعده ونقل
المنكوبين
ومتدرين اكثر من 28
الف جندي تابعون للقوات المسلحه التركيه
ماذا لو موجودون ويبذرون قصار جودي
ويعملون ليلا ونهارا من اجل تقديمه
المساعده الى الفرق المختصه هذا
بالاضافه قامت وزاره الصحابه بتوجيه اكثر
من
1250 سياره
اسعاف هذا بالاضافه الى
انشائي المستشفيات الميدانيه
المتنقله من اجل تقديم الدعم الاوليه
وتقديم الخدمات الصحيه بشكل مباشر هذا
بالاضافه باننا نبذ القصاره جودنا كي تكون
جميع
المطارات الموجوده في هذه البلاد بالاضافه
الى الولايات المجاوره جاهزه لنقل
المساعدات كمالي تقدم الدعم الكامل لنقل
المنتظرين خلال خمسه ايام فقط قمنا باعاده
مطار هاتاي ليقدم الخدمه الكامله لجميع
المتطورين وتقييم الخدمات اللازمه ايضا
لنقل المساعدات والغرفات من جميع الولايات
الى الولايات المتضرره كما قمنا باعطاء
الاوامر والتعليمات اللازمه الى جميع
الوزارات لتوظيف جميع الامكانيات والطاقات
اللازمه الى هذه الاماكن والولايات
المتضرره كما ستقوم ايضا وزاره
الطاقه ايضا
الى هذه
الاماكن كما نشكر جميع
العاملين في مناجم المعادن الذين جاؤوا من
الولايات الاخرى كانوا جبارين
بحفر وفتح الانفاق والمشاركه
الكامله مع جميع الفرق المختصه للبحث
وانقاذ من اجل المشاركه في انقاذ
ناجينا واخراجهم من البنايات المتضرره
كما ستقوم ايضا جميع منظمات المجتمع
المدني ووزاره
العائله بتكفل
اذا للبحث عن اي
اشارات اذا طبعا هذه الصور من انطاكيا
بولايه يا هاتاي هناك معلومات اذا عن
انتشال او اخراج شخصين هما رجل عمره 60
عاما من اسره سوريه هو وكذلك طفله ايضا
اخرجت بعد تسعه ايام
وهي على قيد الحياه كذلك اذا
والبحث الان مستمر عن خمسه مفقودين اخرين
من نفس العائله السوريه تحت انقاض هذه
البنايه كما نتابع معكم في هذه الصور
المباشره ايضا فريق البحث ما يزال يستخدم
هذه الاجهزه لتتبع اي اشارات هي كاميرات
حراريه اذا ترصد وجود حياه او ناجين تحت
هذه الانقاض البحث ما يزال مستمرا عن خمسه
افراد تحت انقاذ هذه البنايه في انطاكيا
بولايه هاتاي التركيه اذا بعد تسعه ايام
من الزلزال ما يزال هناك ناجون يخرجون على
قيد الحياه على ما يبدو والامل ما يزال
موجودا قبل قليل تبعنا كلمه للرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان طبعا حصيله ضحايا الزلزال
ارتفعت الى 41 الف قتيل في كل من تركيا
وسوريا الرئيس اردوغان شبه الزلزال الذي
ضرب بلاده بانه
عادل قنبله ذريه تحدث بان اي دوله طبعا اي
دوله تواجه هكذا زلزال
فانها يعني ستواجه نفس المشكلات التي
واجهتها تركيا يقول الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان قبل قليل مشاهدينا نحن في متابعه
هذا الحدث المتفاعل اذا من
انطاكيا بولايه هاتاي التركيه نشاهد فريق
الانقاذ الذي يستمر في جهوده لليوم التاسع
اذا بعد الزلزال في محاوله لاخراج النجين
ما نعلمه حتى الان ان هذا الفريق نجح في
اخراج رجل سيتيني في عمره 60 عاما اذا من
الجنسيه السوريه وطفله ايضا تم اخراجهما
وهما على قيد الحياه بعد تسعه ايام اذا
تحت الانقاض والبحث الان ما يزال مستمرا
عن خمسه افراد اخرين من نفس العائله
هي عائله سوريه تم الابلاغ عنها اذا وهي
موجوده تحت الانقاظ ايضا في المجمل
العائله متكونه سبعه اشخاص في انطاكيا تم
اخراج شخصين
وباقي خمسه اشخاص اخرين اذا فريق البحث
اذا مستمر الان وهو يبحث عن اي اشارات عن
طريق الاجهزه التتبع الحراري اذا مشاهدينا
تسعه ايام مرت
وما يزال هناك اخبار مبشره ما تزال هناك
يعني ما يزال هناك ناجون رغم ارتفاع حصيله
القتلى بشكل كبير جدا الى يعني 41 الف
قتيل في هذا الزلزال المدمر طبعا ونزوح
مليونين ومئه اي الف شخص اذا نزحوا داخل
الاراضي التركيه كما اعلن رئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان
قبل قليل اذا مشاهدينا
اليوم ايضا مشاهدينا مع القصص النجاه في
هذا اليوم التاسع اذا بعد الزلزال اربعه
اشخاص ايضا كانوا على قيد الحياه تمكنت
فرق البحث والانقاذ من اخراجهم من وسط
الركام طبعا بعد مرور ثمانيه ايام على
وقوع الزلزال المدمر الاثنين الماضي وفقا
لوكاله الاناضول والتي افادت ايضا بانقاذ
سيده من تحت الانقاض بعد مضيه
200 ساعه في ولايه هاتاي
بجنوب تركيا ومن هاتاي نحن نتابع معكم هذه
الصور المباشره نبقى في متابعه هذه القصه
طبعا الجرافات هي بانتظار الاشارات اذا
للتحرك طبعا كما نتابع معكم كنا نشاهد
فريق البحث وهو يستخدم جهازا للتتبع
الحراري للبحث عن افراد العائله الاخرين
اذا فرق الانقاذ كما نتابع في العاجل
تمكنت من اخراج تسعه احياء اذا من تحت
الانقاض اليوم في ولايات مختلفه
نحن نشاهد معكم اذا استمرار هذه الجهود
هناك سياره اسعاف
تتقدم باتجاه المكان او تخرج من المكان
وربما طبعا بعد نجاح هذا الفريق في اخراج
شخصين من العائله رجل عمره 60 عاما وطفله
كذلك كان على قيد الحياه البحث جالا مستمر
الان عن بقيه افراد العائله اي خمسه اشخاص
اخرين تحت الانقاب
اذا مشاهدينا هذا الحدث يفرض نفسه قصه
انسانيه ويعني هي اقرب
معجزه اذا بعد كل هذا الوقت يصمد هؤلاء
الاشخاص تحت الركام ويتمكن فريق الانقاذ
التركي من اخراجهم من تحت الركام احياء
اذا ينضم الينا الان في هذه المتابعه
الحيه من اسطنبول دكتور بكير اتاجان مدير
معهد اسطنبول للفكر دكتور بكير اهلا بك
معنا قبل قليل طبعا استمعنا للرئيس
اردوغان
وطبعا ما يزال يعني بعد في اليوم التاسع
بعد الزلزال يعني العمليات البحث مستمره
وهناك احياء تم اخراجهم حتى الان
هناك عدد يعني لا باس به من الاحياء تم
اخراجه اليوم في تركيا في ولايات مختلفه
كيف يمكن النظر الى هذا الدكتور بكير
تحياتي مساء الخير لكم اولا اولا اريد ان
اوجه نداء الى العالم لانه هذه اليوم كما
هو معروف عفوا يوم الاحبه يوم التضامن الى
جميع شعوب العالم وحكومات العالم الذين
تضامنوا معنا في هذا اليوم وفي هذه الايام
الشكر للجميع واتمنى في الايام القادمه ان
تكون هذا التضامن حل المشاكل التي تتعلق
في الدول العالم وفي شعوب العالم التي
تتالم بين الحين والاخر لان التضامن مهم
جدا والحب اقصد هنا الحب التحابب الاحبه
ايضا مهمه جدا لذلك اتمنى ان تحلل مشاكل
وعلى راسها المشكله الفلسطينيه بين بين
فلسطين بين فلسطين واسرائيل وايضا المشكله
التي ما زالت منذ اربعين سنه بين الاتراك
والاكراد علما بان نحن تاريخيا لا توجد
مشاكل ولكن بعض الدول تفرض هناك مشاكل
علما بانها غير موجوده في داخل ونحن
عائلات لنا علاقه قرابه وجيره وحتى منذ
الاف السنين وايضا اتمنى ان تكون علاقه
على الاقل سلام بين تركيا واليونان من طرف
لابد ان نعرف جيدا بان في حال نحتاج الى
تضامن الى التحابب لان عندما تفرض غضب
الطبيعه تغضب نجد بان السوري والتركي
يلاقينا حتفهم بدون اي تفريق وايضا الكردي
والتركي والعربي ايضا لذلك اتمنى من دول
العالم ان تعرف جيدا باننا بحاجه لبعضنا
البعض وبحاجه الى تضامن
كبير الان وفي المستقبل
لا يموت احدا بالنسبه لي سؤالك طبيعي
للاسف الشديد ما زالت هناك
للاسف قتلى تحت الانقاض ولكن انا ايضا
اريد من الفرق ومن الحكومه التركيه
ان تستمر في البحث عن تحت الانقاض لان اذا
اخذنا بين الاعتبار قبل سنين حصلت في
هايتي
وكانت هناك ناس على قيد الحياه تحت
الانقاط بعض 14 يوم نحن اليوم في اليوم
التاسع اتمنى ان تستمر البحث عن هؤلاء لان
قبل حوالي نصف ساعه عائلات ما زالت تحت
الانقاض وما زالوا على قيد الحياه لذلك
لابد الاستمرار في البحث عن هؤلاء
المتواجدين تحت الانقاب طبيعي ليست سهله
هذه
زلزال شملات اكثر من عشر مدن في داخل
الاراضي التركيه وايضا في الشقيقه سوريا
خمسه وهذا يعني للاسف الشديد عدد كبير
ومن اكبر الزلازل التي حصلت في القرن ال
21 اذا قررناها يعني هناك 15 مليون من
داخل تركيا متضررين واقل شيء 3 مليون من
بكير الى جانب
تفضلوا نعم اعذرني فقط يعني كنا نتابع احد
اعضاء الفريق التركي لانقاذ الذي يقوم
حاليا بالبحث عن العائله السوريه لكن
الصوره انقطعت المباشره الصوره تعود لاعلم
اذا هو يتحدث باللغه التركيه لو نستمع
قليلا للصوت الطبيعي
نعم يتحدث انا انا قبل قليل كنت في حديث
في التلفون الشخص يتقن التركيه واسمه فارس
وعمره 60 سنه
وللاسف الشديد الزوجه حسب ادعائه بانها
توفيت
وعندهم ما زال ثلاث اشخاص على قيد الحياه
والسيده التي خرجت معه طفله او كبيره 16
سنه اسمها فاطمه اعتقد وهم سوريون الاولاد
يتقنون اللغه التركيه قليلا والرجل
يعني هو الذي يعني انت انت تابعت هذه
القصه كذلك ما هي تفاصيل الاخرى يعني قريب
نعم يعني نتحدث عن عائله سوريه المعلومات
التي لدينا تشير الى انه عائله سوريه من
سبعه اشخاص فريق الانقاذ التركي نجح في
اخراج شخص عمره 60 عام والفتاه عمرها 15
سنه
الاب سيد فارس نعم اسمه فارس طيب البحث
جاري عن اربعه ام عن خمسه دكتور بكير
خمسه خمسه العدد المتواجدين سبعه ولكن
نتمنى ان يكونوا الخمسه لكن حسب ادعاء
الرئيس الاسره السيد فارس الذي خرج 60 سنه
يدعي بان الزوجه توفيت في الداخل وحتى احد
الاولاد متوفي ولكن نتمنى ان هذا لن يعني
لن تكون صحيحه لانه هو ايضا في يعني اصابه
ربما يكون مخشيين او شيء اخر نتمنى ان
يكونوا على قيد الحياه لكن عدد الاسره
سبعه بالضبط كما اشرتم قبل قليل
الزوج والزوجه وخمسه اطفال طيب دكتور هل
لديك معلومات التي خرجتها هل لديك معلومات
اكثر الى متى ستستمر عمليات البحث عن
ناجين لانه بعد تسعه ايام يعني هناك من
يفقد الامل في العثور على المزيد من
الاحياء تحت الانقاض بالنظر الى الظروف
المحيطه بالضحيه تحت الركام هل تعتقد انه
سيكون هناك المزيد من الوقت للبحث عن
ناجين
نعم حسب بعض المعلومات غير المؤكده
الطبيعي الى الان بان العمليات سوف تستمر
الى ربما اربع خمس ايام اخرى وهذا الذي
كنت اريده واناشد الفرق الانقاذ والحكومه
التركيه ان تستمر لان ما زال هناك على قيد
الحياه اليوم وامس وحتى غدا سوف
اعتقد بانه يكون ناس ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه وهذه الفرقه الانقاذ سوف تنقذهم
واتمنى ان تنقزهم هذه الفرق يستمر دكتور
هذه مره اخرى نعم كما نشاهد على العاجل
على الشاشه الفرق لانقاذ التركيه تؤكد على
ان هناك شخصين على قيد الحياه اسفل هذا
المبنى في انطاكيا بولايه هاتاي اذا
مشاهدينا نحن في متابعه لهذه القصه معكم
الان في هذه الصور التي تردنا من هناك
القصه هي عائله سوريه مكونه من سبعه اشخاص
فرق الانقاذ التركيه نجحت في اخراج
رجل عمره
حوالي 60 سنه
او 65 سنه وفتاه عمرها 15 عاما الى 16
عاما في بعد يعني في اليوم التاسع بعد
تسعه ايام اذا تحت الانقاض في الزلزال
البحث جاري عن خمسه اشخاص من نفس العائله
وهي عائله سوريه
كانت تقطن في هذا المبنى الذي انهار عليها
عقب الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا يوم
الاثنين الماضي فرق الانقاذ التركيه اذا
تؤكد وجود شخصين على قيد الحياه اسفل هذا
المبنى بعد انقاذها للشخصين اخرين ضيفي
الدكتور بكير قبل قليل اكد ونقل كذلك عن
شهاده فرق الانقاذ تحدث على ان ان الشخص
الذي تم انقذه الذي
الرجل ويعتقد ان اسمه فارس وهو عمره 65
سنه الاب يقول ان زوجته متوفيه تحت
الانقاض في انتظار التاكيد يعني بعد اخراج
العائله كامله
مع هذه الجهود المتواصله الذي نتابعها
التي نتابعها معكم الان اذا على الشاشه
فرق الانقاذ اذا المشاهدين هذه هي القصه
تنقل شخصين اذا الاب عمره 65 عاما وفتاه
عمرها 15 عاما من عائله سوريه البحث جارين
عن
خمسه اشخاص اخرين الفرق التركيه فرق فريق
الانقاذ التركي يؤكد انه متاكد من وجود
شخصين على الاقل باقيان تحت الانقاض هما
على قيد الحياه يبدو ان هذا تاكد من
تاكدوا من الامر عن طريق جهاز الاستشعار
الحراري
الذي شاهدناه قبل قليل وهو يتم استخدامه
دكتور بكر انا اشكرك على هذه المداخله
معنا كنا المفروض ان نناقش موضوعا اخر
متعلق بالزلزال ايضا ولكن طبعا هذا الحدث
وهذه هي القصه المتفاعله فرضت نفسها الان
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه معنا وعلى
صبرك معنا طبعا مشاهدينا الكرام هذه اذا
قصه يعني مثيره للاهتمام بالنظر الى ان
المده الكبيره التي يعني قضاها قضتها هذه
العائله تحت الركام تخيلوا انه بعد تسعه
ايام وفي هذه الاجواء البارده تحت الركام
هناك احياء يخرجون ما زالوا يخرجون يتم
اخراجهم من تحت الانقاض بعد هذا الزلزال
المدمر الذي وصفه الرئيس رجب رجب طيب
اردوغان قبل قليل بانه يوازي قنبله ذريه
ضرب تركيا على العموم معنى الان من
اسطنبول كذلك فائق بولوت المحلل السياسي
استاذ فائق اهل بك معنا كيف تنظر يعني الى
عزيمه فرق الانقاذ التركيه وكذلك الفرق
الاجنبيه وهي مستمره في عم البحث عن ناجين
لليوم التاسع على التوالي بعد بعد الزلزال
يعني عزائم هذه الفرق الانقاذ يعني طبعا
جزء من مهنه جزء من تربيه وحتى اخلاقهم
يعني وبالتالي انا بعتقد انه ليست لن
يستمر فقط
لن تستمر فقط يومين ثلاثه اربعه ممكن يكون
الاسبوع وعشره ايام لان يعني مدى العلميه
يعني علميا يعني مده اللقاء تحت الهديه
الركام تقريبا
تتراوح بين سبعه ايام عشره ايام ولكن بعد
ذلك ممكن ان نعتبرها معجزه مع ذلك يعني ان
كانت هناك معجزه يعني لانقاص حيا ممكن ان
نقول يعني منكوبين ومتضررين تحت ان كانت
يعني
خلينا نقول بعيد عنهم
قد يكون نكون ميتين مفقودين لحياتهم ولكن
لابد من اخراجهم من تحت
بالتالي فرق
ان سوف تستمر اياما فقط ثلاث اربع ايام
نعم يعني ممكن
سمعنا قبل قليل لكلمه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان طبعا هو تحدث على مواصله العمل
حتى انقاذ اخر شخص من تحت
الانقاظ
واعاد كرر وعده باعاده الاعمار خلال سنه
واحده
واعاده بناء 30 الف منزل في المناطق
المتضرره كيف تنظر الى تصريحات الرئيس
اردوغان ويعني تعاطى الحكومه
التركيه مع مع هذا الزلزال المدمر
يعني طبعا هذا الوعود يعني وعود
ايجابيه يعني لا بد من
ترحيب هذه الوعود ولكن وعود شيء تطبيقها
شيء اخر جدا لاننا نعرف يعني ليس فقط
السلطه السيد رجب السلطات السابقه ايضا
كانت وعقد وعدت من هدف بالكلام طبعا من
هذا الغبيل وعوده كانت تناظر قبيل كثيره
جدا كثيره جدا ولكن يعني لابد من مساله
القضيه ولابد من ايضا نسال ان نتساءل يوم
التضامن نعم يوم المحبه تمام يوم التوحيد
خلينا القلوب والجهود تمام هذه كلها ولكن
لابد ان نسال ايضا
ونتسال ايضا لماذا لم تتخذ يعني تدابير
اللازمه قبل ذلك
لنرغم من كل خبراء يعني خبراء الزلزال
حضروا
وطبعا نظموا تقارير وحذروا الى الحكومه
يعني السلطات معينه قبل هذه السلطه وبعده
فلذلك لم
يتهن لم تتخذها بعين اعتبار تاخذه يعني
انتظار هذه مشكله كبيره جدا فهذا كانت
معروفه ان مناطق المنكوبه يعني قبل الشهر
قبل اربعه اشهر او خمسه شهور يعني كانت
هناك تطبيق كان هناك تطبيق حتى في هذه
المنطقه
كيف ننقذ الان ننقذ الحياه
والممتلكات خلينا نقول انسان في هذه يعني
في هذه كارثه طبيعيه ولكن نرى انه هناك
فاجعه كبيره كارثه كبيره جدا
هي هي كارثه كبرى
ولكن مستقبلا لابد
ونشوف كيف يعني بارقه امل ان نكون بعد
تسعه ايام من الزلزال وهناك احياء يخرجون
من تحت الانقاذ شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه معنا سيد فائق اذا مشاهدينا
خصصنا الجزء الاكبر من بانوراما اذن
لمتابعه هذه القصه التفاعليه ما زلنا
نتابع الصور من انطاكيا بولايه
حصيله الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب يوم
الاثنين ارتفعت الى 41 قتيلا اكثر من 35
الف منهم في تركيا السلطات الان نجحت في
اخراج شخصين على قيد الحياه في تاسع يوم
بعد الزلزال شكرا على المتابعه الاخبار
المستمره على العربيه ابقوا معنا